hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be looking at the check over
variation which is a simple approach to
attacking the
sicilian defense sicilian starts out
with e4 and then c5 from black
typically play is going to continue with
knight 2 f3
pawn to d6 this is the open sicilian few
ways in the open sicilian you may see
pawn d6 knight here to
c6 you could also see e6 these are all
pretty common but d6 one of the the main
lines that you will see in the sicilian
defense then after pawn to d4 pawn takes
and now the check of variation because
most people are going to play the main
line and that's knight takes here on
d4 but checkover variation is queen
takes on
d4 now there's three lines that we are
going to look at the most common by far
is what you're gonna see is knight two
c6 develops a piece attacks the queen so
that's going to be pretty common we're
also going to look at pawn to a6 as well
as bishop to d7
so let's first look at the main line and
that is knight to
c6 and i want to go over the typical
moves that you'll see
some of the thought around how you're
going to set up your position and then
we'll look at some variations on how the
game may play out differently if both
sides are not playing the main line so
knight to c6 attacking the queen the
queen does not have to move
but the only way to avoid this is to
play bishop to b5 which is the preferred
method get another piece involved into
the action you don't lose a tempo
because if they just played knight to c6
and you move your queen back they have
gained a tempo or a move in the game but
bishop two b5 gets material involved
into the game and says yeah you can't
take my queen here because this is a pin
to the king here on e8
now they may stop that pin with bishop
to d7 not wanting to lose a tempo we're
just gonna go ahead and exchange right
here keep in mind you do not have the
bishop pair as black so something to
keep in mind you have to make sure that
you get something back and really we
need to make sure that we control this
game specifically from the center of the
board because our opponent has the
bishop pair we don't want to open this
game up and allow them to control the
game with their bishops
we're gonna get more material involved
as we said knight to c3
knight to f6 here and now we're going to
play bishop to g5 this allows us to
castle on the queen side if we want to
and then really launch a strong attack
on the king side you can tell because
they have already removed their c pawn
they're probably not going to castle on
the queen side so this pretty much just
leaves the king side open for them and
since we have a better center control we
have more pieces developed it's a little
bit easier for us to just throw
everything at the king side of the board
and really put a lot of pressure on our
opponent so they really need to play
something like pawn to e6 here
stopping us we don't just
it would be pretty good for white just
to take here on f6 if they recapture
with their pawn on f6
because then after we cast on the queen
side they no longer have a safe king
side as well so really need to play e6
or e5 uh we'll look over e5 as well just
so you can see what happens here but e6
makes a lot of sense now if we capture
they can recapture with their queen
it doesn't matter too much then if they
exchange if the queens are off the board
so typically not going to see that but
now white's going to castle on the
queen's side and then after a bishop to
e7 then white has
rook to e1 and they may castle on the
king side here but you can see white's
completed their development they have
center control both of the rooks are on
the dna file one semi-open file but then
also protecting this pawn here on e4 so
this is really the main line that you'll
see from both sides and kind of the
approach that they are thinking about
so let's look at a few variations off of
that we looked at after knight to c3 if
they played knight to f6 but they may
not play that they could
just try to counter in the center of the
board maybe pawn two e5 uh now they have
a backward pawn here on d6 but this is
attacking the queen the queen's just
gonna fall back to d3 because white no
longer has the light square bishop
doesn't have to worry about blocking off
the light square bishop so just
controlling this light square here on d3
still allows for the dark squash bishop
to get involved into the game uh so this
is a completely fine setup for white and
many times white's gonna be bringing
that queen back down here to
d3 as well so pretty common even if you
look at the position we were just at as
far as how white may continue at some
point yeah they may play king to b1 at
some point but also queen to d3 makes a
lot of sense preparing for the knight to
come over to
d4 at some point as well so that's kind
of the setup that we're looking for
so if we do come back here uh if we see
that e5 and the queen to d3 this is not
a bad thing at all bishop to e7 but now
we're gonna castle on the king side and
the reason for that is usually we're
playing that bishop two g5 to attack the
knight since the knight's not there we
really can't bring our bishop to g5
because they have the bishop and the
queen attacking that square right here
and we don't want to bring it to any
other squares f4 just loses to the pawn
and we really want to be pretty
aggressive with our dark square bishop
and so because we don't have any other
moves right now we can go ahead and
castle on the king side and be okay
because if we cast on the king side
maybe now if they play knight to f6 we
can play bishop to g5
but uh just the slightly different
variation because we've decided to
castle short side instead of queen side
still completely fine just have to be
aware of how your opponent is uh moving
their pieces in what order because that
is going to change how we castle and how
we develop our pieces
now let's say they do actually play the
knight to f6 but then after we play
bishop to g5 instead of e6 let's say now
they play pawn to e5
so now that the queen's under attack we
need to bring our queen back here to d3
bishop to e7 but now we're actually
going to exchange
our
bishop
now they have the bishop pair we have no
bishops on board that's completely fine
but we need to make sure that we
maintain the pressure we're going to
castle on the queen side here
and if they castle on the king side this
is a pretty common variation that you
need to understand in the checkout
variations so there's lots of things you
could see but this one comes up quite a
bit because in this position white can
actually take this pawn here on
d6 now it would be incorrect for black
to go ahead and take here because now
white is
for sure up a pawn in material you can
just count on white has seven black has
six and there's no real way for black to
fight back if they play optimally which
they may not but if they play optimally
they're gonna play something like queen
to
b6
now
uh white's going to play knight to d5
and then they take here we take their
queen and after the pawn takes we take
their bishop here on d5 you can see that
their rook can come down and take here
on a two so if you look at it and say
okay white didn't actually gain a pawn
and material but they can get into the
in-game with a much better setup
and white should easily win this game
now the threat that black has right now
is rook to a1 and that would just
attack the king and we would end up with
an x-ray losing our rook here on h1 so
we bring our rook to a d1 says yeah if
you play rook to a1 then we can just
easily play king 2 d2
but since we are attacking this pawn
here on e5 with both of our knight and
rook they may decide to go ahead and
play rook to a4 attacking our pawn on e4
we take the pawn maybe they take our
pawn here on e4 and then we play knight
to d7 attacking this rook
as well as attacking the pawn on b6 and
the bishop on f6
so rook to e8 makes a lot of sense you
always want to have your rooks on the
same file
this just allows them to really control
the game
if they are working together now this is
a spot that you want to make sure that
you understand the threats that black
has because you may look at it and say
man there's a free pawn here on b6 well
it's actually not free if you take here
on b6 then they have the move rook 2 b4
this is attacking this knight here on b6
as well the pawn here on b2 and the
bishop on f6 is also attacking the pawn
on b2 so in this position you actually
want to take
this bishop here on f6
now is white up a material no white's
not up in material both sides have five
pawns and both sides have two rooks but
if you look at this
black has two double pawns and white
does not have any so a much better setup
going into the in-game and so this is
something where if you're practicing
your in-game this is something you need
to be able to
turn into a win if you're playing the
check-over variation so i used to study
this exact position quite a bit playing
against uh friends and other opponents
to see if i could always turn this into
a victory so definitely a good setup but
you need to understand
if you come back a few moves and they
actually play that castle on the king
side and you take here on d6 how you're
actually going to respond again it's
it's much easier if they just take here
because you you take with your rook and
there's no real way for them to fight
back and get that pawn of material but
they could play queen to b6 you just
need to be prepared
so let's come back to the beginning of
the variation after they played knight
to c6 attacking our queen we bring our
bishop out here to b5 pinning down the
knight to the king
and the first thing we looked at is
bishop to d7 but they may not play that
they could play pond a6 and just say hey
yeah go ahead and take our knight if you
want to i don't want to get my light
square bishop involved into the game
just quite yet okay well we're gonna go
ahead and take that knight they take
with their pawn and now we're going to
castle on
the king side they play pawn to e5
potentially we come back to d3
knight to f6
rook to d1 and the reason we play rook
to d1 because you may say wow the knight
came to f6 it seems like a perfect
opportunity to play bishop to
g5 i always like to play
lines that allow my opponent to get into
a bad position or make a mistake
and that's exactly what rook to d1 does
because they may see this and realize oh
wow they have the next move of bishop to
g5 so if they play something like pawn
two h6 to stop that seems like a logical
move not everyone's going to play it but
seems logical is we can actually just
take here on e5 because they can't take
here because that would be
checkmate so that is the threat that we
have we can take a free pawn here
e5 and so that would be a huge blunder
from them to play h6 so that's why i
recommend playing rook to d1 instead of
first playing bishop to g5 now if they
don't play h6 yeah feel free to go ahead
and play bishop g5 if you want to and
then exchange that's completely fine
then you could play knight to c3
get other material involved into the
game
so that was if they play a6 after knight
to c6 they don't have to do that they
don't even have to play knight to c6 so
we'll look at the next variation that is
just pawn to a6 many times in the
sicilian defense a6 is pretty common if
you're familiar with the nydorf defense
this is a common move that you will see
from black just because it stops so many
moves that white's typically going to
play usually white's looking to play
knight to c3 and then potentially come
up here to b5 play bishop to b5
attacking this king here because it is
exposed since the
c pawn is no longer there so a6 does
make some sense we're not gonna play
bishop to c4 still want to get our light
square bishop involved into the game but
the difference is in this line we are
actually going to have
our bishop pair we may decide to
exchange it off but in the main line we
are for sure always exchanging it off at
least now we're attacking this f7 square
which is a huge weakness for black early
on the king is the only piece that's
defending it so we can change gears a
little bit and play more aggressive
attacking the king side than we have
before
one example let's say knight 2 c6 which
is a common next move to now force the
queen back queen to d3
knight to f6 here castle on the king
side
pawn to b5 extending on the queen side
attacking our bishop bishop comes back
to b3
pretty easy here but now let's say they
play e5
we have the move knight to g5 if you
watch other videos i have talked about
for openings you know this is a pretty
common setup here when you have your
bishop on this light square diagonal
here attacking the f7 square
and you can safely bring your knight
here to g5 you have a lot of stronger
attacks on this f7 square so this is the
threat that white has it's pretty
exciting they have some interesting ways
they can
defend this you know rook to a7 and we
can play things like bishop to e3 um
attacking that but
you know again putting more and more
pressure on this f7 square and even if
there's an exchange it's not that good
for black all of a sudden they have a
completely exposed king it won't be able
to castle and you still have your major
pieces that you can attack so that's
what happens if they play a6 early on
and how you should continue
the last variation we will look at is
instead of knight to c6 instead of a6 if
they play bishop to d7
from here we're going to play knight to
c3 and then after knight to c6 here
we're gonna drop our queen back to d3
and the main reason that they might play
this
is because they want to gain that tempo
they want to push our queen back and
they recognize that hey if they play
their knight first then we can just play
our bishop out here to b5 and exchange
but if they played in this move order
well we can't just play bishop to b5
because they could just take our queen
and we can't take their queen back and
we're also not pinning down that knight
to the king so this is a legal move so
that's not going to be the play instead
we just brought drop our queen back to
d3 now maybe knight to f6
we can play bishop to g5 attacking the
knight pretty common pawn to e6 and you
can start to see this is a pretty
similar setup to the main line
the only difference is we actually still
have our light squared bishop so you are
going to be setting it up very similarly
just know that now the queen on d3 is
blocking the light square bishop so you
may not be playing some of the common
lines that you typically would instead
maybe bishop to e2 to get your rook over
to e1
but all in all it is still pretty
similar to the main line and you won't
see bishop to d7 nearly as often as
you'll just see knight to c6 early on so
that is the checkover variation
hopefully this was a good overview of
how to think about it how to uh attack
the sicilian defense i always am looking
for ways uh to approach a pretty common
defense and the sicilian defense is one
of the more common ways growing up this
is actually how i attacked the sicilian
defense because everyone was playing
just knight takes here on d4 and when
you start to dive in and realize that
queen takes on d4 is a very reasonable
move and you have a lot of strong
attacking lines especially when you can
castle on the queen side and really
throw everything at your opponent's king
side it's a pretty fun opening so
hopefully you guys enjoyed it try it out
if you have played it before let me know
what you think if there's any
interesting lines you've run into always
cool to see what people come up with in
the checkover variation if there's other
openings you would like me to do as well
please let me know in the comments
section below or you can always email me
my information is on my website at
thechesswebsite.com hopefully you guys
have checked it out there's a lot of
cool resources there but thank you guys
for watching i'll see you in the next
video
you